you
looking at the Supreme Court this
morning where justices are hearing
arguments today and a challenge to the
Trump administration's effort to end the
so-called daca program which shields
nearly 700,000 young immigrants from
deportation Carter Evans spoke to former
Homeland Security Secretary Janet
Napolitano who oversaw daca during the
Obama administration
he also talked with a student whose
future hinges on the court's decision I
don't want to be living in in constant
fear not a day goes by that 31 year-old
min-koo Choi doesn't worry about his
immigration status it really dictates
the fate of my life and in my future can
you imagine a life outside the US I
can't it's this is where my life is this
is where my job my my friends my family
is Choi is one of nearly 700,000 daca
recipients nationwide protected from
possible deportation it doesn't grant
you any sort of legal status it's sort
of a temporary immunity so to speak it
just keeps you from getting removed for
the country exactly and allows you to
move about and work and pay taxes
exactly the acronym is deferred action
for childhood arrivals but we call it
Dhaka University of California president
Janet Napolitano implemented the program
in 2012 when she served as Homeland
Security Secretary in the Obama
administration when a young person is
raised in this country our country has
already invested in that young person
they've gone to our schools they're
going to our universities and colleges
they represent a population that our
country should want to have among its
citizenry do you feel like there's
anything you can do
no Choi is a UC student working to
become a pharmacist currently doing part
of his clinical rotation at a Children's
Hospital in central California he came
to the u.s. from South Korea with his
family when he was 15 years old his
parents and younger sister became legal
US residents but during the family's
green card application process
oi became ineligible i aged out you turn
21 exactly his fate is now in the hands
of the Supreme Court which will have to
decide if president Trump's action to
rescind daca is valid when the president
announced his plans in 2017 he said in a
statement I do not favor punishing
children but we must also recognize that
we are a nation of laws the Trump
administration argues President Obama
overstepped his authority when he
created daca by executive action without
consulting Congress I think the
President does get a lot of discretion
to rescind previous executive action
remember that is not a law that he's
were sending it's not even a regulation
Ilya Shapiro is director of
constitutional studies at the Cato
Institute he wrote a brief for the
Supreme Court I'm a supporter of daca of
the dream act of Congress passing
legislation to provide lawful status and
and other benefits to people who were
brought here illegally as children but
the president can't do that by himself
that is just flat-out wrong the
executive has to set priorities and the
executive has to have the authority to
establish programs like dokko the UC
system home to roughly 1700 daca
recipients now plans to present that
argument to the Supreme Court all this
led by a person who set records for the
number of people she deported while
serving under President Obama there are
some who say you are the reason
President Obama was called the DePorter
in chief the numbers are what the
numbers are I think the question is well
who who was in the numbers do you worry
about getting deported I do yes if if
daca is is a cinder then everything will
be stripped away this could be your your
neighbor this could be your friends it
is impacting their lives and my life to
the point where it can destroy and then
erase everything the Supreme Court is
expected to rule by the end of June
around the same time min-koo Choi will
graduate for CBS this morning Carter
Evans Los Angeles